so I prioritize trying to win the battle
in the morning as I had the ability to
see the end before the beginning even
begins you have to first be
uncomfortable with how you feel about
yourself once or mentor today let's
learn from one of the best David Goggins
and how to develop a warrior's mindset
and body mentor me David also if you
want to learn how to build confidence
like David and other successful
entrepreneurs check out my shoes before
series is free in the description below
you will never learn from people if we
always tap-dance around the truth
everything I didn't want to do is what
got me to where I'm at today
[Music]
ok let's get it on rule number one wins
a title in the morning so I prioritized
trying to win the battle in the morning
so I always win the Battle of morning so
I get morning time every morning I go
for a run that's the first thing I do
every morning haven't taken a day off of
running since December 2016
I've every day up in the morning so I
also stretch out every day for about 2
or 3 hours every day I've missed two
days and about five and a half six years
so that's just my routine in about four
days a week I'm in the gym hitting the
weights because you know you can't just
be a runner so this is every single day
the the monotony of my life but this is
what builds discipline you know and not
everybody I'm not telling everybody to
do this but this is my lifestyle this is
how I build self-discipline remember to
visualize the end result is I have the
ability to see the end before the
beginning even begins and what that
means is I know that to get to the very
end I can see it right now so before
with the buds and I was always I saw
myself walking across the stage at 191
pounds guy so I had to get to get into
the door I saw myself six months a year
later wherever's gonna take me to do it
I saw myself walking across that stage
getting that certificate of graduation
from buds and I was able to be there at
300 pounds and that feeling that I was
nowhere near that feeling I was able to
put myself there a million times
everything that feeling of like my god
that is gonna feel amazing that's what
made me suffer that's what allowed the
pain to be realistic this is worth it I
want to feel for this next 18 months
could take me 18 months to finally come
on a visa find me you know just get do
but 18 months is six months took me 18
that's what woke me up every morning was
I won't put myself through this much
pain and suffering for a few
yes so it is a few seconds of joy it's
so worth it man
as a people don't get so I'm able to put
myself at the finish line you know I
have no finish line but at the finish
line of an event before I even start
them say how are you gonna fit into this
visualizing this is my biggest tool of
life that's why I've been able to put
myself in cold water put myself in a
hundred mile race millions of times
before I've done it and I'm able to go
through the race and see I'm gonna feel
at Mile fifty almost to the almost to
the exact exact feeling right so when it
comes up it's no surprise no surprise
I've already done this a million times
rule number three face the real use a
lot of people can live with themselves
look in the mirror and say I'm okay with
being afraid I'm okay with going on this
easy highway over here the easy highway
has all these signs and directions how
to get somewhere and you have to first
be uncomfortable with how you feel about
yourself
with that voice that love us like to run
away from we all have it we all have
that voice that say hey man you know
you're you're kind of wimping out right
now you kind of being a little punk
right now but I would say okay that's
okay it's okay to tell you little white
lies to ourselves so we first have to
face the real you the real me is David
Goggins the real me is a guy looking at
you right now saying I don't want to be
on this show right now because I used to
stutter as a kid and I'm afraid of that
I'm afraid that here in a second I'm
gonna start stammering a stutter and the
whole world is gonna know that I have
all these issues but that's when I see
right now okay Goggins you got to go on
this show that's Goggins Goggins is
saying okay David Goggins you're a punk
life made you this way we can't live
like this we can't live in fear we can't
live in judgment we can't be afraid of
with the people right now looking at me
saying about me we cannot be afraid of
that
that's Goggins Goggins saying all of you
who don't like me who don't want to in
that person then it comes in but you
have to be David Goggins and say man I'm
afraid of this I'm up here life made me
this way here I stutter I
have these issues with reading and
writing and and I'm fat and I'm insecure
you have to face that in that dark room
in that dark room is who you are but in
that dark room is where you have to
create another human being that walks
out of that dark room to face who you
are that's the only way you're gonna get
over all those things you have to create
someone else not like you have two
different personalities it is you but
you have to find strength in that
visualization of almost me cracking out
Goggins like almost like that Superman
cape like I'm coming out a different
person a person that doesn't give about
anything he doesn't care about being
judged who knows I'm weak who knows I'm
afraid who says whatever you think about
me take it whatever I'm here that's
guidance in the dark room you face
yourself you realize you want to be
better you realize you don't want to be
this weak insecure person in the world
he has all these problems that we all
have we all have souls of me is a great
platform to tell you who we want to be
now who we are so that's where that dark
room is rule number four out work
everyone work out my work ethic from was
the hours I had to spend learning this
when you sit down and you're not smart
you have a disability yeah and you still
want to be at the top of your class I
didn't want to get by what I realized
that I can learn through hard work and I
can beat the valedictorian in school but
I got put in ten hours more a day than
he does you know what kind of strength
comes from that when you're sitting down
that guy that that valetroy study for an
hour and you know I caught you I caught
you and I am dumb but I have the work
ethic to catch you that's where David
gagas got really invented yeah was at a
kitchen table with 20 spiral notebooks
that were empty and then three months
later they were full and you can go to
that I have me my storage and you go
through these power notebooks of your
life and you're like this is how
I learned this is unbelievable there's
no miles it's not about the miles is
that having a discipline every day they
say for me to learn this one math
problem it's gonna take me ten hours mom
and that's where it you realize do hard
work you can do you can outwork anybody
how bad as they are but that's the part
people don't want to dive into and rule
number five the last one before a very
special bonus clip is it race to suck so
when things hit you in life that you're
afraid of or you're not good at the
first thing you're gonna say to yourself
is why am I here anyway this isn't for
me
the water is too cold the sun's too hot
I'm getting up too early why am i doing
this to myself that's what the normal
mind says I had to start training my
mind to think about how the can I get
through this not giving myself a way out
never give myself creating a wall around
all the ways out in my mind and a slowly
starts to build this wall so my mind
noon this is not gonna give himself a
way out of here
in my first home we had a huge setback I
was broken my legs were broken at double
pneumonia I got rolled back to day one
week one of Navy SEAL training I got
through that second hell week during the
second hell week I actually broke my
knee I continued to limp around for a
couple weeks I couldn't make it anymore
got rolled back to day one week one I'll
never forget standing there in front of
Captain Bollinger he was a co in charge
of Navy still train at the time and he
had no mercy on anybody if he believed
in managing your expectations I wouldn't
be here today he
again I was challenged my whole life not
by the mindset of managing expectations
by exceeding expectations not by
managing them I'm standing there with
crutches I'm sitting in his office he
looks at me he goes jogging this year
last time we're gonna push you through
Navy SEAL training this would be your
third hell week in one year we're not
gonna put you through a 40 so this is
your last time I'm sitting thinking how
am I gonna get through this I'm badly
jacked up my legs are broken my knee is
messed up and he goes he have a couple
of months to get better a couple of
months isn't gonna do it I won't get
healed up a couple of months but I
realized I'm going to get through this
I'm gonna find a way to get through it
cuz why I put barriers in my mind so my
third hell week I went in there with
pretty much I would put a black sock on
first I would get duct tape and I
duct-taped my ankles all the way up to
my calf every single morning then I put
another black sock over it and what that
did that prevented me from moving my
ankle so I didn't really I wasn't
flexing my shin as much that I started
running with just my hip flexors then
this hell week it was a bad Hill we had
a guy died on Thursday morning of hell
week I went on to become a Navy SEAL
greatness is not something that you meet
once it's something that should meet
thousands of times in your life and you
don't reach it if you're not constantly
in constant pursuit of greatness so if
my mom would say right now I'm great
I just lost we're gonna grow we're not
gonna triple down on our strengths we're
not gonna do that crap we're going to
work on our weaknesses so we grow we
need friction to do that without
friction there's no growth without
friction this confusion confusion is
David gagas how did you become who you
are today
I put a bunch of friction in my life
and I grew that's how I did it you know
you get really tough it's a lifestyle
instead of hitting that snooze button in
the morning and not making your bed and
not cleaning your house you don't need
this news button you get up you don't
want to go run you go run you don't want
to go swim you go swim you wanna make
your bed you make your bed you know
where a kid in your house you clean your
house you don't want to study study
that's how you start to callus your mind
so that became my life if you say you're
gonna wake up at 4 o'clock in the
morning to go run wake up at 4 o'clock
enough it's gonna suck it's not gonna be
fun do something that sucks every single
day of your life that's how you grow
embrace the Sun know there are social
skills from deeper how to accept what
you're not that I think you're really
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
let's go from just watching another
video and taking action your business or
life here we go question number one what
does winning the morning look like to
you number two spend five minutes to
visualize the end result that you want
what do you see and number three where
do you just need to embrace the suck in
the book you tell people to make a list
of everything working against me every
real valid excuse right why do you have
them do that there's a lot of power in
that list so in that list of who you are
what makes you [ __ ] up all these are
things
it goes back to once again accepting you
have to first accept it before you can
fix it a lot of people walk around oh
man I'm good I'm good
no you're not you have to accept which
you're not you have to and people don't
want to do that that's the only way you
can fix it you have to accept it first
before you can go on the journey a lot
of folks never even start the journey
man then they would start to join me
because I live in this fake life that
who they want to be they act like they
are but they're not because they haven't
fixed all this stuff yet you got fixed
this first
before we can start our journey in life
so that's why I haven't make this list
you fixed these problems now your
journey can begin because you no longer
care about how people are judging you
we when you care more about how
someone's judging you you're gonna stay
right there
there's no four-momentum so that's one
thing about that list
if you want more diamond Goggins check
out the top ten rules video I made with
him the link is right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
I'm not the smartest kid in the world
okay it says am I saying
oh no you're smart no no don't say that
to yourself I said to myself no I'm a
dumb